let's I'm going to stay here oh okay
right there come over alright well we'll
just get into this because I have a
whole list of questions and how many
we'll get through so I'm going to
selfishly ask a question because I'm
very interested when you started VMware
was in late late 90s little irritating
time how many were any of you in Silicon
Valley in 98 raise your hand okay we got
some hands we got some hands I want to
hear more about it I want to hear what
what was Silicon Valley like and sort of
how did you get started with VMware yeah
well the way it was interesting the way
I got started I was I co-founded VMware
with my husband as a professor at
Stanford and he was doing research and
he had he had sent me an email was
actually that one startup I didn't
mention I was working on at the time and
he sent me this mail I because I I was a
sort of a adviser to that so I never
counted but um it actually went public
but but anyhow I was he got this email
from all these people up at Microsoft
about a paper that was supposedly under
blind review and I'm like oh man you
really got to get a patent filed here
and and then I'm like you know this is
just so valuable your research we should
take it to market and and and and then
we kind of did it with our grad students
and we were you know it turned out it
was just we did this thing and it was
right at the beginning of the dot-com
era and there was pets.com and web and
calm and and you know these companies
that were raising huge amounts of money
and I can remember I went to some party
and I'm talking to this guy and he's
like what do you do and I'm like well
we're building this software that you
can put on your machine light you run
multiple you know it'll multiplex all
the resources and he just looked at me
and he goes this is hopeless you know
and and like you really got it like a
dubious idea do in fact I couldn't even
get a PR firm to come and work
us because it was all about thinking big
and this whole dot-com thing it was a
and it was um it wasn't that hard to get
engineers because we were such deep
technology they understood what we did
but but getting business side people was
pretty much impossible and so companies
were just sort of getting slapped
together and going public well I don't
know if they were slapped together but
they were going public right and left
that's for sure yeah in fact the company
that I advised in one public I was
stunned do you have any equity I did I
bought this Bazaar so so then did your
husband how did tell me how you got
started specifically with VMware did he
say ok come on board now is like we're
making well with me I was like I think
you should do a company and I said I'll
help you and and famous last word and
then I found out I was pregnant and I
said look I really
I'll get it going but then like you know
I'm about to have our second kid and I
was like can't do a startup and and and
I and then we had his two grad students
that were going to join us and and so I
said I better tell him I'm going to have
a baby and I did and they were like so
and and so I'm like ok so we did it and
then six months into it I had my baby
and it was kind of cool because we
didn't have any customers and we were in
this little building that you could open
the windows and so I just brought my
baby to work and hung out with her like
a little bassinet oh yeah where was I
was office in June oh it's funny it was
you know yeah you know near town and
country there's a carwash yeah so it's
right behind there and healthy on have
been there before and they moved out and
they called it the crack house because
people were doing drug deals right next
year baby and but it was a it's the
building is not there any longer so did
you then what did you fun
grace for VMware Leonor how did that
work because I'm interested in what
fundraising was like back in well you
know so I'd made money from the extreme
the video the streaming video company
from Microsoft and I always delighted
and telling Steve Ballmer and whatnot
that they paid for the extreme because
they didn't it wasn't really a great
company for them because we got in
between Intel and Microsoft in the stack
so we disintermediated them a little bit
and so but anyhow so we have money so we
what we did was we did a
friends-and-family and we only allowed
friends and immediate family to do a
seed fund okay and then and I held back
on how much I put in to kind of be fair
to you know all the founders and then we
said okay let's do an outside just to
get some credibility and and this is
sort of advice I've always giving people
is you want to find investors that
really deeply understand what you're
doing and so and you want to get rich
people that deeply understand what
you're doing and so that's what we did
we got Andy Bechtel shame and few other
peope people done Hennessey so how did
you get did you know Andy like what we
kind of knew him we were a bunch of you
know pretty deep engineers and you know
we were kind of new the new the
engineers and Andy's a bit really a
phenomenal engineer and and David his
partner David Cheriton was a professor
at Stanford that I go answer fool ya a
certificate it was by winter being buddy
and and so we just called them up and we
told them what we were doing and yeah
they were seed investors in Google -
yeah and and and it took an hour only
because they they got it they're like
whoa yeah so they're kind of like that
famous Google
three were and he wrote the hundred
thousand dollar check and said here you
go yeah we got three hundred thousand Oh
better story that is so great yeah he
said you know I gotta check books at my
house and he's like I'm gonna leave it
you know like um in my driveway you know
and I got his address and I'm like is
this his house and it was like
newspapers all over the pidrive way like
he hadn't even been there I'm like is
this really the right and there was the
envelope oh my god a month in it sorry I
live for this stuff all these random
little details make things so colorful
so then you stayed on after the birth
well so thinner yeah it was working so
well and I was having fun and I
convinced my mother to come live with me
part of the village to help with my
daughter and but I and I brought her
with me along in fact she was raised
she's like the same age as the EM we're
really interesting and so I can always
remember how old VMware is and and and I
just brought her everywhere like when we
got more advanced and I started having
customers and partners all over the wing
all over the world she went all over the
world with me and then I would just stay
at a really high-end hotel and have them
hire a really high-end nanny to take her
and you header of her and take her
around and if she just loved it oh I can
imagine it really high-end hotel okay so
things are going looking back on VM WA
what were there any mistakes that you
made there that you said gosh for my
next startup I'm going to be sure not to
do this I'm always interested in I think
the biggest mistake I made was getting
you know feeling like it was selfish of
me to not sell you know because
everybody else wanted to and I I was
like thought it we're co-founders or
fellow founders wanted to sell and and I
thought it would be selfish not to
although they would have thanked
he had I not but in hindsight I'm
actually really glad that I ended up
leaving VMware because I I probably
wouldn't have left and I had several
years with my kids just home with them
that I really valued but which I might
not a catcher it was a fire afterwards
yeah
did your investors want you to sell were
you the only one that well I didn't have
any C's so no we didn't have these C's
so I took money after after we took the
money from Andy and David and John we we
raise money from Dell and and from Dell
and and a few banks that were wanting to
take us public ok so you were really in
control of things like yeah we were
totally and totally in control which is
obviously the kind of place without
having to do the ten to one um so then
been to one voting rights you had some
time with your kids and then you joined
the board of Google and yeah right after
I left the MRI during the board of into
it and and then a few years later I
joined the board of Google yeah okay so
I'm curious being on these boards of
these super successful companies in
addition to running your own super
successful company what kind of things
did they have in common or not in common
that that make the wouldn't say too many
companies have much in common with
Google yeah that's true
well what it was it about anyhow things
about yeah I've had people it's about
the people that's what I mean certainly
in Silicon Valley everybody focuses on
the people and and so maybe it's just
across all of Silicon Valley and but
those are you know Intuit and Google you
know it's funny they had Bill Campbell
in common kind of but they were so
different the board meetings and
everything and really the only female
board know Google I when I joined had
and still does Shirley Tilghman home
resident not anymore but she was
President of Princeton
and and then and Mather who was who
still is chair of the Audit Committee
phenomenal board member and so I'm a
third woman to join that board which is
it makes a huge difference to have three
instead of two we actually you know have
conversations in the bathroom probably
very rare okay so in 2012 you started be
Bob and you're very much in stealth mode
right if I remember I singer what do you
yeah well because it was such a big
ambitious open you know sort of
investigation I saw no reason and there
was too much interest yeah everyone
wanted to know what Diane Greene was
working on so what what made you how'd
you come up with the idea what made you
want to work on this and sort of how did
that one well I had actually been trying
to convince anybody that would listen
that they should go start a company to
do it because it's very familiar my
husband is like that yeah I just like I
really thought you know this layer of
the stack where you build the
applications for the enterprise you know
because it's so much more complicated
where you have multiple users and access
controls and it's really hard to do it
well and I like it really needs some
attention and I kept that was sort of
the vision so you were bugging other
people I had this great you really
should focus on this there's the need so
you saw this need and did you finally
say well as well then the co founder I
found a professor at Stanford II he was
like yeah let's just do it and I'm like
well okay if you'll do it I guess I'll
do it and then he said he bailed and
then then I just like thanks a lot
wasn't your husband well no he didn't he
came in after I'd been kind of working
on it for a while
Seavers a solo founder well then I
convinced some of my friends from VMware
to come in and I said oh why not we'll
just call you a founder
okay so what what was it about and they
were great people and they're still
there and you worked with them before
yeah it's just the mama had that really
she is so what was it that you that made
you think this is an important thing
that needs to be working what was
missing currently why what was there
weren't good solutions out there well
like have you ever used some of them no
no have been already ever used
enterprise software you know so it over
it's um you know it's layers and layers
of clicking through these screens you
know we're really like maybe you just
talked to slack I mean do you really
have to you know it's just so convoluted
and complex and for power users you have
to have all this rich functionality but
it doesn't have to be you know this this
layer of screens that you know like you
can use machine learning and things and
know what the person is trying to do and
help them do it and you can
automatically fill in everything and you
know you can just make it like when
you're using it you're just going how
did it know that's what I was about to
do and it just makes it there for you
and that's what you you know it's it's
just incredible what you can do today
that is radically different from what
you know back when we certainly when we
founded that I think people are doing
that now I even think Google G suite is
doing it but I you know everybody's
doing it more and more now and
especially the phone drove a lot of it
because you if you didn't do it on the
phone nobody was going to use it but
back then it was a lot worse yeah so
then what made you decide you're working
on the super ambitious plan that you
know is broken and you're gonna you're
going to do this what made you sell to
Google well so so one thing was there
were a few things going on one was that
in terms of being on the alphabet board
by then Noah was still Google it was
just become no it was still the Google
board anyhow as part of my work on the
Google board I got involved in Google
efforts just because a day and can we
ask your questions and so I I really
made very good friends with or huzzle
who is the guy that really he's employ
number eight at Google he'd built all
their employees of amazing person and
really enjoy and I mean I tell this he
lives near me we started walking our
dogs every Saturday we became very good
friends and talked about I was just
fascinating so that was good and then I
was getting to learn all about Google's
technology and and the AI and the
machine learning and them you know just
everything that Google has the Maps and
knowledge graphs and so forth and I
realized that if you combine that with
what bebop was doing it would be pretty
special so they were so and I was busy
kind of helping them find someone to
come in and run Google Cloud mm-hmm and
we worked really hard on that and sounds
like it no I gave them so many names I'd
like this is the person you know and
because I really wasn't interested at
all and and and they convinced you that
and and and then I just started what was
a combination of bebop it both things
kind of but anyhow the last person I
thought they were going to hire I
thought the person was great they
decided not to there I thought maybe
they weren't googly enough or something
and it was in Heinz anyhow so so at that
point I just said okay if we can make
this work for B Bob and I talked to
everybody at B Bob you know to make sure
they would be okay with it and yeah we
had just raised a lot of money from a
16z and Mark could join my board and god
yeah
were they supportive yeah I mean they
weren't that thrilled but they weren't
going to right problem they certainly
respected what we wanted to do
and it's and it has worked out super
well and I have to say I'm glad I did it
the cloud is like it's really
interesting yet tell me about what it's
like running running this the class so I
mean for me being in the enterprise for
so long and and seeing what's happening
in the cloud is is it's just I mean I am
where with like a big sort of mini
revolution this is like a giant
revolution and everything and the
enterprise is just moving so fast and
and you know everything's going to be in
just a few maybe four clouds or so you
know there's not going to be that many
of them because like we spend about ten
billion a year in infrastructure and so
it's not going to get disrupted by a
start-up unless they invent quantum
computing or something but I mean it's
been invented but they make it work but
we have a process we have a project to
make it work to but but the or make it
it works actually now but it's hard to
use it's hard to program yeah it's
almost impossible and but it will get
there sorry did I grass but okay
so anyhow it's just you know because you
know with mobile and being able to bring
all the data together and have the
security of the cloud like like our
world you know you look at these
ransomware attacks I mean we need more
security and you're going to get it in
the cloud and you know you look at
something like you know you want your OS
in the cloud updated constantly and tiny
and monitored you know and you know it's
it's like Gmail you know we over 1.2
billion users so we can see everything
going on and respond immediately and we
can be constantly vigilant and you just
you know that kind of security you can
get in the cloud isn't it isn't
available to to a company and and then
you know the advanced technologies are
there so every you know everybody's
going to move to the cloud and then once
you have that scale what you can build
because of what
you're seeing is kind of revolutionary
so it's fascinating Wow we're running we
have now one say I have to ask one last
question even though we've just run out
of time if you could warn first-time
founders about a mistake that they're
going to make what might it be
you might not make anyone a takes oh
everyone makes mistakes what a lie like
I would say you're going to make it a
little hard way what's something they
might learn all that way that if you
tell them about maybe they'll try to
avoid that well one thing I was I was
listening to all these incredible
answers that people were giving to this
question so one thing I didn't and they
were all great the one thing I didn't
hear people talk about was sort of board
your board of directors which i think is
I mean it can be something you manage or
it can be something that helps you and
and you really want to try and have a
board that you don't have to manage but
that helps you like at VMware I was able
to select my board it's a I keep we
don't have time to go into the story of
how I did it how I pulled it together
but I picked the people that really had
the unique kind of expertise I wanted
and then my board meetings I never wrote
slides I just wrote a document and it
and it had a few metrics about how we
were doing if you know we were doing
well but the whole rest of it was things
I was worried about or trying to figure
out and so I had a board that I could
trust so much that I could just say look
here's the things I'm wrestling when
let's talk about it and I don't have to
impress you at first was I never tried
to impress any of them yeah okay so the
board and how you did you are there any
is there any advice on selecting those
people it's just people like I'll give
an example of what I did you know I
decided so because we sat between the
Intel hardware and the Microsoft
operating system
they were both monopolies and so it's a
little bit sobering and and so I'm like
wow we got to do all these deals and we
got to struggle with Intel and Microsoft
and and
and I wanted to do all these
partnerships with the hardware vendor
big companies like IBM so I thought I
need someone that's really seen a lot of
deals and knows how to structure a deal
and at the time you know Larry son
Seanie was a managing partner at Wilson
Sonsini he was I remember on the cover
of American Lawyer or something as the
ultimate power broker and everything any
I decided that was who I needed on my
board and we don't have time where I'd
go into it was a really you know fun
little vignette when I got him to join
my board but you know that was the
example so when I went in to him I just
explained to him why I needed him and
what I was doing and why you were
specific because when I walked into his
office and said I wanted him on my board
he said well I'm pretty busy getting off
boards and I know and there's a lot but
then I showed him how what he knew how
to do was unique and he had no idea who
I was and how what I knew what he knew
was a unique fit to what I was trying to
do and you got him to say yes and close
the deal he's like it was really funny
because he's like okay well think about
it you know kind of thing
it was a Friday light and I came in
Monday morning and I got in at 7:00 a.m.
and I my son was already and I'd been in
on Sunday so my phone was lit up you
know back then before shell funds and I
listen he goes hello Diane or I can't
mimic him but anyhow he said I'm
inclined to droid your board and I'm
like what is inclined to me he goes I'll
drawing oh my gosh that's Korea oh wow
when I got that happy note yeah thank
you
so
thank you
[Applause]
you